wird ein verbrechen von 1989 bald
aufgeklärt ja vor 31 jahren wurde die
damals 32 jährige beatrix hämmerle in
ihrer wohnung brutal ermordet in der
nähe des tatortes wurde eine lederjacke
gefunden und jetzt gibt es die
möglichkeit mit einer neuen möglichkeit
mit neuer technologie ein dna
sicherzustellen
diese wurde sichergestellt wir sehen
hier gerade die lederjacke und jetzt
soll es eben zum dna massentest kommen
500 männer sollen getestet werden und
soll dann noch der täter geschnappt
werden
dieser fall wurde auch gestern abend in
der sendung von zdf aktenzeichen xy
ungelöst vorgestellt und jetzt möchte
ich mit dem kriminalbiologen mark
benecke sprechen erst mehr live
zugeschaltet guten morgen herr benecke
guten morgen könnt ihr uns vielleicht
einmal erklären ist es überhaupt noch
möglich nach so einer langen zeit ja in
den match zu finden
ja das ist ohne weiteres möglich die ab
substanz hält sich sehr gut solange sie
also trocken gelagert wird und nicht
irgendwie mit feuchtigkeit oder anderen
zersetzung bedingungen berührung kommt
kann man sich also sehr sehr lange
untersuchen und teilweise auch noch
jahrzehnte später das ist also kein
problem und können wir uns vielleicht
das einmal so ein bisschen uns laien
technisch erklären wie das dann
funktioniert 500 männer sollen jetzt
getestet werden wir haben es gerade eben
gehört wie funktioniert es dann bis man
dann wirklich einen match eventuell
findet also da gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten entweder findet man direkt
einen treffer das heißt es wird so ein
wattestäbchen genommen so ähnlich über
den corona test dann können alle
menschen freiwillig übrigens ihre ab
substanz abgeben und die wird dann
datenbank mit anderen bereits
vorhandenen spuren in dem fall eben der
spur von der jacke verglichen jetzt gibt
es aber eine neue möglichkeit eine
zweite und die führt dazu dass man gar
keine ganz direkten treffer mehr braucht
sondern man kann auch die
verwandtschaftliche ähnlichkeit
herauskriegen also wenn ich bei dir sind
menschen die jetzt zum dna test geben
einen genetischen fingerabdruck
entwickle und sehe dass er ähnlichkeiten
hat mit denen die man auf der jacke
findet dann kommt kann man halt herum
suchen und die betreffende person fragen
sagen sie doch mal haben sie einen
cousin cousine können wir mal in ihren
familienstammbaum anschauen
das ist jetzt relativ neu das wurde
früher nicht erlaubt und so kann man
auch nur
über eine verwandtschaft ähnlichkeit
einen sagen wenn man in direkten treffer
auswerten und somit dann auf den
möglichen echten theater kommen